a quick note before we get started while
it will not be the primary focus of this
video there will be references made to
various forms of sexual assault if this
is triggering for you you may want to
skip this video
and coming up next on bbc one a weasley
defense of transphobia and a commitment
to not improving stay tuned
[Music]
so
the bbc
if you've been watching my doctor who
content over the last six months you may
have noticed that at the front of the
videos there was a notice pointing out
the issues of transphobic reporting from
the news arm of the british broadcasting
corporation
well
i've got some updates on that front that
i think i need to get into this is not
how i wanted to start pride month but
here's the short version i'm still going
to be putting that notice in front of my
doctor who videos though i'll probably
be putting a shorter version of it
pretty soon uh the longer version of
what's been going on well
strap him we've got stuff to unpack
i got to do some background on this
first though
on october the 26th of 2021 the bbc
published an article titled we are being
pressured into sex by some trans women
it was a one-sided poorly sourced
article featuring the opinions of mostly
unnamed lesbians claiming they felt
pressured to have sex with trans women
regardless of their own preferences much
of the data featured in the article came
from the organization get the l out an
activist organization which openly
protests against the rights of trans
people especially trans women
while the article features many quotes
the vast majority of those are pulling
from other sources such as previously
written articles by other people youtube
videos and previously made official
statements by various organizations one
of the few named people actually
interviewed and quoted in the article
was adult film actress lily kade while
the article was already causing a stir
upon its initial release with people
taking issue not only with the general
tone premise and sourcing for the
reporting but also
pointing out almost immediately after
publication
that lily kade had a known history of
sexual abuse of women in other words
she's actually confessed in the past to
doing the very things that these women
claim to be concerned about trans women
doing
the bbc issued no response to those
concerns and initially made no
amendments
then november happened
at the start of november of last year
lily cade published a blatant call for
violence against trans women on her blog
now i went over this in more detail over
on the vero wild channel so you can
check out that video for a more thorough
breakdown but to pull an illustrative
quote in reference to trans women kade
wrote if you left it up to me i'd
execute every last one of them
personally
a few days later the bbc removed her
contributions from the article and added
the following addendum to the bottom of
it we have updated this article
published last week to remove a
contribution from one individual in
light of comments she has published on
blog posts in recent days which we have
been able to verify we acknowledge that
an admission of inappropriate behavior
by the same contributor should have been
included in the original article
and yes i am going to be doing mocking
voices for the bbc all the way through
this
uh i found it of note that the bbc
did not condemn the comments
all they said was that the comments made
were the reason that she was removed
from the article but more tellingly i
think is that sentence that second
sentence rather
they say that they should have noted her
history of abusive behavior in the
article not that she shouldn't have been
included at all because apparently the
bbc feels that a woman guilty of the
exact acts that she is positing trans
women are liable to engage in would
still have been fined to include as long
as her own history of abuse was noted
the idea that kade's history of abuse
wouldn't just completely preclude her
inclusion is both baffling and troubling
to me
and i also feel it's worth noting kate
is not from the uk she's american
so she wouldn't even have been included
in the get the l out survey that was
done in the uk that served as the basis
for much of the article
now
even after the removal of kade's name
and the quotes that she gave from that
article
there's still a great deal wrong with it
in terms of offering a platform to push
transphobic rhetoric by an openly
transphobic organization like get the l
out and people made their complaints
about this known the best documentation
of these complaints being registered and
also the bbc's attempts at dodging them
was done by the youtuber sean who's done
at time of recording three videos on the
topic starting in november of 2021. he
went through the complaints he
personally issued to the bbc advised
others on how to submit their own
complaints on similar or the same issues
and reported on the bbc's responses to
him and the tactics they employed to
wriggle out of any responsibility so
if you want to blow by blow on that
aspect i would recommend his videos
the reason i actually feel the need to
make this video
in case you were wondering why i've been
citing stuff from october and november
of last year
well it's because the executive
complaint unit otherwise known as the
ecu they're part of the bbc and they
have issued their findings on the
complaints about that article now those
findings were made public near the end
of may meaning that it took nearly seven
months for the reply to the complaints
to come in now
i admit
i don't know what the average amount of
time is for the ecu to put out a
response to complaints i did try to find
out but all i could find was what the
target goal amount of time was but no
actual hard data on what the actual
average amount of time is
however there's another recent bbc issue
that i can compare it to if you'll
pardon me a minor indulgence
so on march 24th of this year on bbc
radio 4 tom sutcliffe while speaking to
philosophy professor eric hatala mathis
he said the following i mean you bring
up the case of jk rowling who clearly
has a very unpopular opinion uh
regarding uh gender identity um and and
has um as a consequence of that as has
faced you know severe and serious
criticism the bbc received a complaint
over the phrase very unpopular opinion
that complaint was responded to
five days ahead of the ecu reply on the
october article in other words assuming
the complaint was made on the day that
conversation aired on radio it was
responded to in two months
also a quick note about my language you
might have caught there you may have
noticed that i said that the bbc
received a complaint about the radio
interview a
as in one as in singular that's not
presumption on my part that's the
wording on the ecu's reply
a listener complained now for reference
the reply to the complaints on the
october article starts by saying the ecu
has received a significant number of
complaints a complaint by a single
solitary person was resolved at more
than triple the speed of concerns
registered from a significant number of
people oh and before we leave this topic
the ecu agreed with the complaint that
it was misleading for set cliff to
characterize rowling's view as unpopular
and to be clear
that was not even the focus of the
conversation that was a passing remark
made to establish a point of reference
while talking to someone about the
general topic of separating ours from
the art
the ecu in its response claims that
while rowling's views
quote clearly proved objectionable to
some there was no conclusive evidence
that the objectives represent a majority
okay there's a couple of problems there
firstly majority in and of itself is
actually kind of a useless word majority
of what majority of uk residents
europeans global population bbc news
itself is a global network as is
evidenced by the fact that you don't
actually have to be a uk resident to
register a formal complaint over its
coverage because it's a world news
service but let's assume that they mean
that there's no evidence that the
majority of uk residents object to
rowling's views well okay specifically
they say there's no conclusive evidence
now conclusive uh is a term that is not
defined
within this and it's easy enough to
debate over some people still say the
human impact on climate change isn't
conclusive despite decades of study and
the overwhelming majority of evidence
all pointing to the exact same thing so
i'm not even going to try and bother
litigating conclusive but evidence yeah
yeah there is evidence actually the most
recent survey i could find conducted in
the uk on how the populist views trans
people was done in 2020 by the research
and analytics firm yougov and there they
found that 40
of the uk general population agreed with
the statement a transgender woman is a
woman and 41 percent agreed with a
transgender man as a man now that's
versus 36 percent of the population
disagreeing with either of both or both
of those statements now while that
margin is
troublingly slim it's still pretty clear
the notion that trans women aren't women
or that trans men aren't men is a
minority opinion otherwise known as
unpopular opinion in the uk according to
the most recent available data but
saying so is apparently
misleading and that's only using one
interpretation of the term unpopular
where it's uh saying that it's actually
held by the minority which isn't the
only definition of that word the most
i'll budge on this is that perhaps
sutcliffe could have clarified among
what groups or specific populations
rowling's views are very unpopular
because yeah they are
but that's not the path the ecu walks
they say it was misleading to call those
views unpopular at all
but okay
coming back to the october article i'm
not going to go through this entire
reply line by line though i will have a
link for it in the description if you
want to do your own more complete
postmortem on it but i am going to be
going through a lot the ecu groups the
significant number of complaints into
three major categories one failure to be
appropriately impartial on the topic per
bbc's own guidelines two harm or offense
caused by the reporting and three
inaccurate or misleading information now
i'll go through these one at a time but
to spoil the ending a little bit the ecu
only upheld a few very specific
complaints on the issue of it being
misleading and rejected all other
complaints but i want to talk about the
reasoning for doing so
so let's break down how that went
on the issue of impartiality the bbc
rejected comparisons of trans issues to
those of racism or homophobia this is
something that's been brought up before
about the bbc's reporting to simplify
things the bbc is meant to be an
impartial news organization and as a
result it has certain standards to
provide opposing views on various topics
so some of the complaints felt that the
bbc's policies on impartiality and what
it is or is not supposed to be granting
a platform through the news service
should have precluded the publication of
the article at all because there are
some topics on which the bbc does not
provide a platform for opposing views
and those include issues like racial
equality and gay rights basically it's
the position of the bbc that these are
issues which are not up for debate by
reasonable people and it won't give
airtime to french or extremist points of
view under the guise of impartiality
however the bbc has said before and
reaffirms in this ecu response that they
do not believe the issue of trans rights
to be comparable and to still be a
matter of legitimate debate this is
consistent with previous comments from
bbc higher-ups saying that impartiality
actually is why transphobic views
deserve a platform
my wording there not theirs but you get
the gist of it the other side of
impartiality complaints is that the bbc
policy and guidelines on controversial
subjects which is as follows when
dealing with controversial subjects we
must ensure a wide range of significant
views and perspectives are given due
weight and prominence particularly when
the controversy is active
so if the bbc is rejecting the idea that
trans right is a settled issue like gay
rights and civil rights for people of
color then you might well assume that
that would make it a controversial
subject and an act of controversy and
therefore the problem with the article
would be that it provides no opposing
voices to the views expressed aside from
quoting a public statement made by
stonewall that wasn't specifically
addressing this topic or in relation to
this article it would seem the ecu would
disagree on that
get ready for some labyrinthine logic
here whether or not there are concerns
in this area is not a controversial
topic but a question of fact
the evidence included in the article
even without reference to other evidence
gathered by the author but not included
was such as to establish that there are
such concerns it might well have been
foreseen that reporting of this fact
would give rise to controversy for
example about the incident or
significance of the phenomenon reported
on but that does not make it itself a
controversial subject requiring the
inclusion of a wide range of significant
views and perspectives to be reflected
if that sounded a little bit like word
salad to you let me help this is
actually kind of a fascinating excerpt
because it lays bare a very specific
trick being employed by the original
article so the ecu is dodging the issue
of whether or not the notion of trans
women pressuring lesbians into sex is a
controversial topic by claiming the
article isn't actually about that
instead the article is about the
concerns people have
about that and such concerns exist that
is a fact the substance or validity of
these concerns is completely irrelevant
in reporting like this this is a trick
really common
to the right wing here in the u.s though
it's by no means exclusive to them but
when a news organization or a politician
say wants to push a narrative that they
know they don't have fact-based
reporting to back up they will instead
talk about the concerns people have
about the issue this is the exact trick
that's being used to bring about voting
restrictions in the wake of the 2020
election because there's no actual
evidence of fraudulent voting in that
election okay actually that's not true
there was one case of a guy in
pennsylvania who voted twice although
for trump
there is however absolutely no evidence
of mass voter fraud on anything close to
a scale that would have actually changed
the outcome so instead right-wing news
and politicians talk about all the
concerns people have about the voting
process the bill is needed because
americans no longer trust the system and
use those concerns to justify their
reporting and their actions because yes
people have concerns invalid and
provably false concerns
but those concerns do exist and if you
keep citing those then you can push the
narrative you want without ever actually
technically lying about it that's the
trick the original article used and now
the ecu has inadvertently put
the spotlight on that fact it's a report
of women's concerns not of actual
incidents but it paints a narrative
shaped by those concerns and never asks
whether or not they are justified
concerns because asking such a question
would clash with the intended narrative
so you just
don't really address it and you instead
hide behind the idea that you are simply
giving voice to people's concerns
okay so that's how the ecu dodges
impartiality complaints let's talk about
the issue of harm and offense
i know in the response they actually
tackled this one last out of the three
categories but i'm saving the misleading
section for last because that's the only
one where they upheld any part of the
complaint now on the issues of harm the
complaints the bbc received were that
the article itself presented a harmful
stereotype of trans women making the
article itself transphobic before we get
into their response the guidelines for
bbc reporting when it comes to this
issue are as follows content broadcast
or published by the bbc may reflect but
should not perpetuate the prejudice
which exists in our society
and that output which includes views
which might incite hatred or cause
offense must have a clear editorial
justification and include appropriate
challenge and or appropriate context
and again given the nature of the
article the voice it gives to those who
feel trans women are predatory and the
failure to provide challenge or context
one would see where the grounds for
complaint would be under this
the ecu would again
disagree and if
if you're already frustrated things are
about to get worse
the reply states he
referring to the head of the ecu noted
that though the concept of pressure to
have sex invoked by the headline could
be regarded as implying impropriety on
the part of those supposedly applying
the pressure there is nevertheless a
distinction between coercion which would
generally be regarded as reprehensible
and persuasional advocacy and that there
could well be instances where one party
experienced pressure what the other
party regarded as good faith and
legitimate persuasion so what's being
said here is that pressured into sex a
phrase that appeared in the title of the
article uh and effectively still does
though not in that exact wording we'll
get to that eventually but that
pressured into sex could be seen as an
accusation of impropriety but it could
also be reflective of actions that only
one party saw as coercive and the other
person was simply putting forth what
they thought was a fair and polite offer
or expression of interest
they're using the idea that pressured
into sex
could be a one-sided interpretation of
events a point uh never made by the
article itself
they use this as an excuse to let the
phrase and the concept stand despite
all the horrid implications a phrase
like that brings with it
hold on
we're not done it goes on to state the
article included one instance of
behavior which could be regarded as
coercive if uh accurately reported in
the case of an unnamed respondent to the
get the l out questionnaire who claimed
to have been
graped by a trans woman and there was no
suggestion that this reflected on the
behavior of trans women in general
okay so
after claiming that pressured into sex
wasn't automatically referring to
intentional coercion the article then
defends an instance where an unverified
source makes that exact claim so the ecu
is attempting to claim that because
pressured into sex is interpretable when
it comes to the intention of the alleged
perpetrator and because the article
didn't outright say that the most
extreme example cited in the article is
reflective of all trans women that
everything's fine
this is the kind of hair splitting that
drives me
absolutely up the wall it only counts as
transphobic if we literally say all
trans women are like this
yeah it's true the article never said or
strongly suggested that the alleged
assault of an anonymous survey responded
was indicative of trans women as a group
however what it did was put forth
unchallenged concerns sourced from an
openly transphobic organization and
cited a specific claim of the most
extreme possible validation of those
concerns the article effectively said
lots of lesbians are worried about
coercive trans women and also here's an
accusation of a trans woman committing
sexual assault and now the ecu is
claiming that's fine because those dots
weren't explicitly connected and then
expanded out to apply to everybody
but the framing still matters and let's
not forget that the original version of
this article featured an interview with
a woman who was confirmed to be sexually
coercive towards multiple women
another thing that i want to draw
attention to
is that
the reply points out the article does
note that angela wilde one of the
founders of get the l out is considered
to be transphobic now this caused me to
actually go back and look at the
original article and i caught something
that i hadn't noticed before
because yes it is true that the article
says angela's views are considered
transphobic by some
however
this isn't brought up until after the
sixth and final mention of angela by
name and it was after the word
transphobic had already been used within
a context where it was exclusively
brought up to point to a term that women
said was being unfairly thrown at them
in other words the article deluded the
power of the word transphobic by using
quotes that questioned its validity and
didn't apply it rightfully to the head
of an openly transphobic organization
until the last possible moment where it
could point that out basically it went
like this here's some women who say
they're unfairly called transphobic
here's angela let's talk some more about
angela here's another woman who say
people call her transphobic unfairly
let's have angela express her views
freely here's a woman who said her own
girlfriend called her transphobic you
know some people out there claim
angela's transphobic
do you see how that structure and
progression makes the acknowledgment of
this woman's transphobia as meaningless
as possible yes technically the
acknowledgement is there but that's the
whole design of this article and this
response to pretend presentation and
context don't shape opinion and to keep
everything at the most granular possible
level because the overall view makes the
problems incredibly self-evident the
last thing i want to cover from this
section is that some of the complaints
expressed dismay that the addendum note
regarding the removal of lilly k's
contributions failed to name her or any
of the issues with her comments which
again to be clear were made after the
original publication of the article
now this is a complaint i share because
basically going
there were some things in here we took
them out because the person later said
some bad stuff allows the bbc to dodge
the weight of the issue over exactly
what kind of person they had platformed
the ecu reply justifies this dodge by
saying the bbc has to consider how to
describe offensive materials without
repeating and perpetuating any offense
it may cause and the head of the ecu
believed the absence of detail was
justified in this instance
that's [ __ ] weak so first of all
nobody said you had to repeat kate's
words trust me nobody should ever have
to read what she wrote i deeply wish i
never had
all you had to do was say due to openly
hateful statements made by lily kade in
the days since the original publication
her contributions have been removed from
this article or
anything along those lines say who it
was so that those who do want to know
what she said can look it up on their
own and be plain about the fact that she
was hateful instead the bbc did neither
hell
they hem in haw over how they should
describe offensive material when they
don't even label her comments as
offensive in the addendum they're just
comments she has published
okay let's get to the complaints about
the article being misleading the one and
only area where the ecu upheld any of
the complaints because with the
publication of this reply from the ecu
there were two edits made to the article
the first was the title the original
title of the article was
we're being pressured into sex by some
trans women and it's now
the lesbians who feel pressured to have
sex and relationships with trans women
less punchy title to be sure but as the
ecu findings bear out the original
article implied a focus on the actions
of trans women when it's much much more
about the opinions and concerns of
certain lesbians headlines matter
because for many people if they see a
headline that appears to support a
belief they already have
many of them won't even bother to read
the article so that collective we along
with a focus on the action of trans
women were legitimate issues with the
title of the original article they're
far from being the only or biggest
issues but they were there if the
article is gonna stand this is better
there you go bbc you improved one thing
have a biscuit
but like a digestive biscuit not not one
of the good ones the one other edit to
the article is in reference to the
survey conducted by get the l out which
i've brought up a couple times the
article now states correctly that the
survey was not statistically valid since
the respondents were self-selecting and
get the l out is an active campaign
group on lesbian issues translation
the data is biased as all hell
the response from the ecu goes into
decent detail on how the original
presentation of this data gave a false
impression of trans women being sexually
coercive being a wide spread
problem
i think it's interesting to note that
the original article did say that it was
a survey of only 80 women i'm honestly
kind of surprised the ecu didn't hide
behind that and claimed that that note
alone was sufficient to demonstrate that
it wasn't statistically valid
instead
they appear to be prepared to cop to the
fact that the average reader wouldn't
know whether or not 80 self-selected
people are a valid pool for statistics
or not and the readers need to be told
whether it is or isn't
of course
the current version
of the article
while noting that it's not statistically
valid does immediately follow up that
admission with a defense of including
the data anyways direct from angela
wilde herself thus doing its darndest to
weaken the legitimate flaws of including
this data at all bbc you can have
half a digestive for that one but that's
it
no more biscuits
now they didn't uphold all the
complaints on accuracy
there was more hair splitting over
presenting quotes that said sexual
coercion of lesbians is a quote huge
problem but i'm running out of spoons on
this so i'm going to jump to the last
major point that i want to cover
and that's chelsea poe
this is the issue that sean hammered the
hardest in his videos that i mentioned
earlier chelsea poe is a transgender
adult performer she was interviewed for
the article but no parts of her
interview actually appear now that in
and of itself is not actually a problem
it's frustrating sure but a journalist
isn't required to make use of every
source they reach out to if they feel it
doesn't meaningfully contribute to the
topic
now the problem
is what was claimed in the article about
the absence of any trans voices the
article states in addition to veronica
ivey i contacted several high-profile
trans women who have either written or
spoken about sex and relationships none
of them wanted to speak to me so the
problem is that the article states that
no high-profile trans woman with a
background in sex or relationships was
willing to be interviewed despite a
trans porn star having been interviewed
that would appear
to make the statement that nobody wanted
to speak an outright and provable
lie
and now comes the most infuriating hair
splitting yet whether the description
high profile if it's a particular trans
woman is clearly a matter of judgment in
which there may be a subjective element
so although the head of the ecu accepted
that some would regard chelsea powers
fitting the description he did not
believe it would be a serious inaccuracy
to describe her otherwise
so the way the ecu is trying to wriggle
out of this is by focusing on the
specific
phrase high profile and while it
acknowledges that chelsea poe
could be considered high profile it
wouldn't be inaccurate to say that she
isn't either
so it's the same well it's debatable so
we don't have to address it nonsense
that was pulled back on the issue of the
phrase pressured into sex
but there's a core fundamental
contradiction here
poe was clearly high profile enough
for the author of the article to reach
out to her in the first place
that would seem to be inherently
qualifying wouldn't it if she's not high
profile then how the hell did you even
reach out to her at
all
so she's high profile enough for you to
know of her find her and ask her but
that status suddenly becomes debatable
enough that apparently it isn't a lie to
not include her and then say no
high-profile trans women would speak to
us
there's some other stuff in the response
about whether pose contributions were
relevant enough to bene have been
included or whether they should or
shouldn't have been but honestly that's
all besides the issue she was
high-profile enough to call but the
article still says no high-profile trans
women agreed to talk this is a lie
regardless of whether or not the average
person has any idea who chelsea poe is i
sure didn't before this all went down
it's irrelevant because within the
context of the creation of the article
she was high profile enough to be
contacted that makes her high profile
for the purposes of this article
period
bbc i'm i'm gonna have to ask you for
those biscuits back you don't deserve
them
so there we go
seven months and who knows how many
thousands of detailed complaints
and what we have to show for it is a
title change and a weak and immediately
undercut acknowledgement that the data
is sh
two
tiny portions of a nearly 4 000 word
article
that otherwise stands with the official
bbc news seal of approval
and the rest of what we got is hair
splitting that misses the point
technicalities that ignore context and
the obfuscation
of opinion
and this
is why that note of my issues with the
bbc is not going away
anytime soon
i'm sorry to kick off pride month by
bringing everybody down with this it's
not technically a kickoff but it's my
first saturday video for pride month
uh
but
what are your thoughts on any of this
i did my best to try and parse this but
obviously i am an outsider to the uk and
to the bbc's
ways of doing things so if i got
something wrong
tell me politely
and whatever your thoughts are
no personal attacks
please not to the original article
writer
not to me not to other commenters
but
just express yourself politely
and whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments and we'll
talk about it if you want to support my
ability to make videos like this patreon
is what enables this to be my living
and enables me to address the issues i
do
in the manner i do
and the amount of detail that i do them
so any amount you can support is greatly
appreciated but there's also memberships
to this channel both of those carry
various benefits that you can look into
and engage with i have other things that
i do there's tons of links in the
description to other projects i have
merch for sale i've written books
there's all sorts of stuff but don't
worry about it
much simpler thing like share subscribe
they help they help battle the algorithm
an algorithm that has never liked me
just like it's being my job as it has
honestly never liked me but um
you know what
you don't even have to do that i'd
appreciate it certainly but the
the thing i want you to remember
especially in pride month
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you
are the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
hey end credits time which means i need
to shout out some patrons this time i'm
going to be shouting out robin moore
zubin lutfalla turak oliver b melinda
walters
the oath the boy tt for knobby lacks the
poodle zach paul idoln tracy scrapbot
vincent paul bartolucci angry casper
toku bl whovian adam rdl taylor shane
ross shaylee gourley and brendan larose
you want to hear me mispronounce your
name check out rewards on the patreon
thanks for all your support
[Music]
foreign
[Music]